j'appelais course parce qu'en fait vos
parents sont d'origine allemande oui ils
sont allés aux états unis ça veut dire
cours voilà ça veut dire quoi vous êtes
loin d'être court 1 ça c'est sûr vous
êtes un humoriste doué de dons de
voyance et de télépathie le tentation
désir bridge est une énigme pour la
plupart des gens à 15 les réaliser
xavier ses capacités on se fait tout en
développant
c'était une progression normale comme
l'apprentissage de n'importe quoi
d'autre
puis c'est tout ce que vous pensez là il
sait tous que dans vos têtes non c'est
pas vrai on va voir moi on m'a dit que
par exemple vous savez faire tourner les
aiguilles d'une montre des trucs comme
ça où quand on ouvre un dictionnaire et
qu'on pointe un mot vous savez qu'elle
nous on a pointé c'est ça bruno que vous
l'avez vu vous bon j'ai rencontré gary
par le biais de jean yves robin les
produits caméra café avec nous et on a
sympathisé on a passé une soirée
ensemble une soirée qui a été filmé mais
pour nous comme ça juste pour avoir le
souvenir dans cette rencontre et on est
sorti on était assez troublé c'est à
dire que moi je lui ai dit si tu as un
don bontin mi temps voilà celle apportée
ces essais apte à porter ces noms dont
constituer un truc tu es un génie mais
j'ai vu des trucs absolument effarant je
sais pas si pour aller refaire là mais à
l'occasion en fonction des taux qui va
nous faire je pouvoir à contrôler ce que
vous pouvez faire
ameline mes vignes et connaissez déjà
mais n'est déjà fait les centrales
ambitionnait
d'avoir vu c'était d'abord décédé jax et
méline voilà
mon dieu
tout l'alphabet parker
soit je m'en sers toujours parce que je
suis toujours en période d apprentissage
de la langue française et allemagne est
ce parce que je sais que vous êtes une
femme menace le loup des steppes c'est
quoi celui-là oui j'ai des perles mais
jeudi et
vendredi
alors petite expérience et de
la
livre avec cap après
800 700 pages des milliers de mots sur
sa cage à recommencer demain j'aimerais
que vous mettez au doigt ou voulait dans
le livre
attention romane quelque part au milieu
quelque part
c'est fait regardez la première bourse
lepage ça va ok et i am a regardé de
dison de troisièmement ce troisième
ligne
ça va ok regardez moi ici excellent
maintenant imaginez que vous êtes de
retour à l'école la petite école les
années qu'on apprend bien de lire et
bien écrire le mot qui vient de choisy
d'henri fait partie de la dictée vous
aimez la dictée n'est ce pas une recette
vous devez écrire c'est mon hockey
comment son premier relais tu as we une
taie oui et vous et en accenter deuxième
lettre
c troisième lettre
elle fait ça très bien alors doivent
être qu est le mot complet pour une
écriture très rapide mais peut soigner
écrire le mot ténèbres
et vous le mot éclairé hu
[Applaudissements]
suivent en temps
je vous entends penser
ou de n'importe quelle page
et plantez vos doigts sur la page où tu
veux soit sur patte gauche ou de droite
qu'il voulait et elle maquille monkey
est prêt doit doit non pas un petit mot
comme lola aussi aux non ça serait un
vrai supporter un mot benon un bol en vo
doit chercher le mot qui vous plaît ok
je me changer les idées si vous aussi
bien à la fin du livre flic c'est une
bonne voulons
quand j'étais moi le voulais je le
visualiseur il est évident que laurent
superbe toutes les lettres sont mêlés
c'est sûr comme jouer au scrabble vous
n'êtes pas de ce lexique un petit peu
bon choix de personnes
ok voyons si nous sommes sur la bonne
piste c'était quoi la première lettre ah
non pas une mais oui bien sur la bonne
piste la deuxième lettre est le
troisième lettre au maire de meaux
complet excellent soft très étanche à
qui des dictionnaires passé le
dictionnaire à thierry servi chaud chez
lepage
quatre-vingt onze dans le dictionnaire
ou le vol
ne changeait pas l'idée c'est gelé ses
cd quand le côté droite quand l'un
portait droite ouais 8e définition dans
la colonne côté droite 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
premiers toutes les milliers de mots
dans la langue française que le mot pour
le vent je sens que ça va être bon je
suis très troublé je sens qu'il va dire
le bon mot voulais je le dise oui
asservissement c'est ça
combien de personnes ici nous allons
faire le tour de table il aurait
assuré qu'il ne pensait pas la même
carte parce que ça arrive souvent que
les gens sont ensemble même si vous
n'êtes pas pour les allemands sont
les premières photos mentale d'une
quatre roues chevrier
et romans films des images noir dans ta
tête d'accor et même évité un jeu de
leurs cinquante deux cammas ne restait
coteaux de jeu ouvrir le jeu rwasa
premier photo mentale d'une seule carte
d'accord les yeux fermés
maintenant jeter un coup d'oeil sur l'a4
ça va excellent et je vais parce que nos
rapports même chose les 4 500 baup façon
d'autres voies jetez un coup d'oeil sur
une seule carte tu me 10,9 non
incoryable hockey ce que nous faisons
ici c de réchauffement
tout le monde autour de la table une à
la fois juste ouvrir les joues roses à
plein nez photo au mental d'une seule
carte ça va ok on fait le tout
une date fixe de 8
excellent et services devraient
participer aussi excellent
on commence avec vous c'est la première
chose c'était plus compliqué j'ai fait
comme avant taille devant tous les deux
aux yeux vous allez chacun crée une
faute au mental
quand j'étais moi votre image
votre image de la carte
j'ai l'impression d'une carte de valeur
à ses hôtes oui
très haute
boost 4 plus ou moins bas
car nous en train de projeter l'image de
deux coeurs et vous les marges de dame
de pique oui
effectivement à votre image c'est la
garde noire un trèfle 1 2 3 4 5
et 4 rouges des carreaux joie 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 non 8 oui j'ai eu des colloques
et tous en même temps aujourd'hui moi
vos images ah oui cela c'est un
excellent avec la dg chez forte
impression de 9 à l'epic l'as de coeur
une quête de truffe est il cet écart
aussi je viens de nommer votre image
déshabillez vous
sa mairie
de coeur pour moi
et le jeu en souvenir merci c'est un
boulot vous de jeu parce que c'est lui
les joueurs de bord de grands joueurs de
poker et
hino pas elle est la plus grosse somme
d'argent que vous ayez jamais perdu au
poker a bondi
500 euros
et les gagnants étaient incertains
mademoiselle rien
négocié en fait 250 me jeu c'est vrai
que c'est bien en 2005 et s'était 2500
euros c'est vrai
je suis impressionné
s'appelle oriane j'ai perdu une somme de
1500 salles
lasser
mais là je veux dire moi je veux dire ça
pue cette histoire désolé vous l'avoir
présente dans nos villes gary s'est dit
qu'est ce que ça va avec il accouché
récemment dit
non non non non je vais le prendre mais
il va être génial pour faire les
interviews
qui cultive pas en patagonie
location d'un
chalet j'ai dit que je ne cultive pas et
que je ne sais pas cultiver refroidir
s'arrête alors catherine je dois dire
j'étais tout non évidemment tout le
monde vient de le voir vous êtes au
bataclan le combien à
27,28 attentes je le savais j'ai lu dans
vos pensées
alors vous allez pouvoir regarder le big
air valid ait mort d'homme et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu